this is on the glass closet and I
thought it would be perfect to talk to
these guys about this if you don't know
the term the glass closet it is I'm
gonna read this because I want to get it
fully right it is a term used for a gay
person usually a public figure or
celebrity who has never publicly come
out as being gay but is basically known
to be gay there are many of these people
now I'm not gonna out anyone we had a
debate before the show
I'm not going to out anyone here but I
have written four names here on this
piece of paper and I don't want you guys
to repeat these names but there are four
names here that are very very public
people in Hollywood won a major TV star
won a major movie star won a major music
music star etc that pretty much everyone
in the gay community knows is gay again
I am NOT outing anyone I just want you
guys to look at this let's keep it on me
for a second so that the white shot
doesn't even see this okay now we're
just looking at that one of them's big
in news and sort of has been outed
recently by a major newspaper okay now
my question is this yes with these
people I have no reason to think that
any of them are anti-gay actually some
of them have done publicly Pro gay
things but yet they still refuse to just
say it and I'm curious as out people you
guys put a lot of stuff out there you
put your full selves out there you put a
lot of skin out there on top of that
literally you're putting your skin in
the game yeah skin into his game
whatever whatever works really how I cuz
I feel very conflicted by these people I
have no doubt that they're all good
people and privately doing good things
I'm probably living happy lives and all
that but as out people how should we
feel about this group of people that's
sort of is tacitly endorsing this idea
that you can live your life still but
don't say it either one of you take it
away I would say that the coming-out
process is different for everyone and
that there's no right way to do it
there's no time that you need to do it
by and and not that I'm letting any of
them off the hook but that they're
probably at potentially at different
points that are coming out journey and
so I think it's very hard to be critical
of people and and
and where they're at and we see the same
thing with with youtubers like that
there's youtubers that are in the closet
and it's easy for us as out youtubers to
say like what are you doing like come
out you can do so much for the cause you
will help change hearts and minds but
they just might not be there yet I mean
there's a lot of processing that has to
happen to get to that point right now
again I don't know anymore they're
waiting for the book deal so that's I
think maybe one more because I don't
know any of these people personally but
I'm look at the four people that I wrote
down here I'm pretty sure these are all
millionaires probably multimillionaires
and isn't that that tacit endorsement
that they're sort of saying well I could
lose this you know and I could lose my
TV show I could lose my movie etc etc
isn't that sort of the worst message you
could be sending to a 15 year old that
maybe wants to go in the movies you know
you know it Amin it wants to be an actor
isn't there isn't the subliminal message
there that this is almost like the worst
thing you could possibly do I mean if I
were to speculate and I'm not not really
in a position to do so I can only speak
from my own experience but one of them
is also fairly quite young as prominent
of a figure as he is so I think that
it's their own emotional journey and I
have no problem with them choosing to
remain in the closet because they are so
prominent in the public eye as long as
you're not living a life of pot
hypocrisy so as if you're not you know
vocally voting voting against gay rights
or or expressing your disdain then we're
cool and as far as I know most of these
people have also been vocal supporters
of gay rights they've just never joined
the club themselves they've been like
they're like oh yeah gays are great love
gays that's not me but love the gays
right so but that's the weird thing and
I think that's why everyone feels so
conflicted when I showed you guys this
list you both sort of backed up like oh
[ __ ] we better not talk about that list
because there is this unsaid thing right
that we shouldn't really if we were to
say this these names people would go
berserk right I do want to respect
people's privacy I know that coming out
was a difficult process for myself and I
wasn't even online when that happened
this was just my own little world I was
so
you afraid so one can imagine just what
they're going through so I want to be
responsive to that and I would like to
and once they're out I tell me your
story girl let's let's let's hear it
what I said I totally agree because
that's why I did the segment like this
and didn't plaster their names and
everything is the hypocrisy issue is
that the big one for you if you saw
these four names and saw that one of
them was somehow doing some sort of a DJ
thing would that lead you more I mean
that's what what leaves the bad bad
taste in your mouth so so so to see I
think that's we're across the line and
the message that you were saying of like
you know they're millionaires and
they're afraid they're that's probably
not the message that they think that
they're putting out I agree I don't
think they're proactively believing that
they're doing something bad but I do
think especially for one of these people
who's an actor who it's so hugely
successful there's somehow the
implication that my success is based in
me not coming out and I think that's
really dangerous and I know that doesn't
mean I'm gonna out him or even think I
don't even think poorly of him I don't
know him but I I think that that
conflicting message is still something
that the gay community hasn't quite
grappled he thinks the message that he's
putting out is it's none of your [ __ ]
business
yeah and and this is my personal life
and it's and it doesn't matter it
shouldn't be like the message that we're
receiving isn't the same message that he
thinks he's putting out and and it kind
of is what it is yeah I did both are
valid yeah I think his perspective it is
it is valid there are certain things
that as public as I am there are certain
things that I just don't talk about
right and you're not gonna get me to
talk about them because it's none of
your goddamn business will you at least
write them on this paper I'll tell you I
don't talk about my I don't talk about
any group but in any relationships cuz
I've seen your youtuber celebrities and
we all see you know when you get into
very public romantic entanglements in
the public eye it just the follow it's
never very good I don't know when you
started your blog you did talk about
boyfriend's guys that you were dating
it's separation of church and state
let's keep something sacred for him his
sexual orientation for some of these
people sexual orientation might be
sacred space for them I don't know